hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
cryo-em and development of
ketamine-based antidepressants i am
jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr ashujia zhu principal investigator
and group leader of the laboratory of
structure function
proteins at the institute of
neuroscience in shanghai china
dr
you may now begin your presentation
hey hello everyone
my name is shuja zhu i'm coming from the
institute of neuroscience
chinese academy of sciences
it's really a great honor to join this
is some official scientific webinar so
today i will talk about crowd em and the
development of ketamine-based
antidepressants targeting to the nmd
receptors
uh a very brief introduction about my
own research experience so i have been
fascinated by the physiological robes
and their receptors for the past decade
so i did my phd training with dr pierre
parletti at a colon homologue here in
paris where we took
advantage of the electrophysiology to
studies about physical gaiting and the
pharmacological properties of the nmda
receptors
so then i moved to
u.s and did my postdoc training with dr
eric guo at the volume institute where
we use the crowd em to elucidate the
four lens uh nmda receptor structures
so i joined uh institute of neuroscience
outcast in
2016 and currently in the lab we are
studying all different
subtypes of nmd receptors by combining
the structure and the functional
approaches
so nmd receptors they belong to the
inotropic glutamate receptor family
which are mainly expressed as excitatory
synapses they are termed as the
coincidence detectors as the activation
requires the binding of co-agonists
glycine and glutamate as well as the
relief of the voltage-dependent
magnesium block
so those nmd receptors they are highly
permeable to calcium and widely involved
in the synaptic transmission and the
plasticity
so studies in the past decade has
demonstrated that the dysfunction of
those receptors
may contribute to a series of brain
disorders
for example the hyperactivation of the
nmda receptor may lead to adpd
depression seizure chronic pain and a
traumatic brain injury
while the hypofunction or
hyperactivation of those receptors can
also
link with the cognitive impairment
schizophrenia and also recently
discovered anti-nmd receptor on
cervilitis
so one of the drug called the momentum
is an uh traditional nmda receptor
channel blocker are widely used for the
early stage amendment management of the
alzheimer's disease
so today we will
focus the topic on the depression
so depression also termed as a major
depressive disorder is a very common
mental disorder so according to the uh
who's uh statistics
globally more than
300 million people all over the world
suffered from the depression and this
number is definitely increasing year by
year
and uh more women got affected than men
and once you get to the symptom it can
last for uh
almost 10 years
so uh in the
uh in the depression field there are two
main theories uh highly linked with
clinical medications actually uh one is
the monoamine theory so which predicts
an impairment of the uh in the
monoaminological function so actually
most of the currently available
antidepressants were taught
were designed to target to the
monoaminergic system
for example the famous ssri
is
designed to block the serotonin we
uptake and maintain the high level of
serotonin in the synaptic cleft
so but i think there are two main
disadvantages of those ssris one is that
they take they typically take the weeks
or even months to produce the effects
second they are ineffective in one third
of the patient
so then it comes with the second series
the glutamate theory uh which indicating
the ear balance problem in the
depression patient so in
2019 fda approved this private from
johnson johnson
which is the first drug targeting to the
glutamate theory for the treatment
resistance depression as well as the
depression patient with suicidal
thoughts and actions
so the effective molecule in this
provider is called the academic
is also a
non-competitive non-competitive nmd
receptor channel blocker
so the main advantage of this drug is
its action speed is really fast
typically within hours
so let's take a
look at the brief history of this magic
molecule academy so it was initially
synthesised by a
american chemist
steve in the lab then it was widely used
as an aesthetic drug for soldiers during
the vietnam war
so as you might know between
the 70s to the 90s in the last century
ketamine began to be popularly used as a
club drug
so
then
i think almost all the western countries
made the academy as a schedule the
street control the substance so it seems
that the drug this molecule was sent to
death for the drug development
then in 2000
a double-blind pre-clinical trial
accidentally uncovered its rapid
antidepressant effect
so this trial was conducted by a group
by a group from yale university with
only seven depression patients so all
those
other subjects
evidence the significant improvement in
the depression symptom only four hours
after a catamine treatment and this
effect can even last for several days
and also recently uh this science paper
published in
2019 showed that
in the chronic stress the animal models
there's a significant
reduction of those spam protons in those
mice while catmin treatment within 24
hours can significantly restore those
spine formations
also a study from uh jojang university
by doctor who highlands lab showed that
in those uh stress animals so there's a
brain region called the lateral hepanula
there's some abnormal
nmda receptor activity induced bursting
frequency in those uh stress animals
while catmin treatment can block
those bursting and to rapidly relieve
the depression
so it has been long known in the field
that
academy is an nmd receptor channel
blocker but nobody really visualizes the
ketamine binding site and understand how
ketamine blocks the activity of those
nmda receptors so that's the aim of our
research project
so as you might know nmd receptors so
they are molecularly and functionally
diverse so in in the rodent brain so
there are total
in total seven subunits with a highly
spatial and the temporal expression
patterns so the functional nmd receptors
they are typically tetrameric examples
so uh for our structural study we picked
the glue n12a and the glue and one to be
those two subtypes for the structural uh
study as there are two major subtypes in
the adult uh four br in the adult for
brain region
so we spend a long time to
to to express and purify those two human
nmd receptor subtypes so as you can see
that
eventually we got the tetrameric formed
blue and one two a and grand one 1 2b
nmda receptors and we also confirmed by
electrophysiology and the binding essays
that those purified the tri uh
catamerical receptors have a similar
ketamine sensitivity as the four lens
nmda receptors
so uh
thanks to the crown em eventually we got
two data sets with s ketamine bound
uh human group n12a or human grain 1 2b
nmda receptor structures
so eventual the final resolution is the
3.5 and strum for 2a and the 4 angstrom
for 2b so as you can see that is the
whole touch tetrameric receptor is a
huge
protein complex
so with the glue and one subunit uh
marked in gray here while a glue and 2a
in in green while grand 2b in blue
here
so with both two data sets as you can
see that the receptor those two
receptors they have a huge
extracellular domains
a fragment
of the
and there's a transmembrane domain so
with both two data sets so the
transmembrane domain was
consisted with the gate
on the top and the selectivity filter on
the bottom uh with
a
central vestibule in between so with two
both two data sets we discovered this
electron density for s-catemine molecule
in in the in the central vestibule
so to confirm that that those
electron density are indeed the signal
for the academy molecule we also
elucidated an april receptors structure
for the gluten 1 2b nmda receptors so
every everything is the same it's just
that we didn't added academy for the for
the uh in the protein
preparation so as you can see that
clearly there's no density in the uh
central vestibular uh in this april
state receptors
so next to gain more insight into the
binding of s catemine we carried out an
md simulation with s catemine bound the
transmembrane domain of the glue and one
2a receptors as as an initial structure
so the md simulation showed so in total
we we performed the 3 500 nanosecond md
simulation so as you can see that md
to show the larger fluctuations of this
s
s catme molecule during this total 500
nano second simulation so we classified
so its initial state was in blue
actually so we uh we you can see that
the catamine molecule can move to a to
the lower pose which is
in close proximity to the selectivity
filter
so
uh
then we we analyzed the author's md uh
data and we we we we showed we we
reviewed that
this second the amine of the catamine
can form a hydro hydrogen bond with the
polar asparagine 616 position in the
glue and one subunit in the selectivity
filter so this this
configuration was only captured in this
lower post
by md simulation and we also know showed
that the s cadmium can interact with
this losing 642 position in the glue and
to a subunit through strong hydrophobic
interactions in other fig configurations
so next we need to confirm that all
those structural and in silica
observations are
indeed
present in the in the in the native
tissues then we carried out
electrophysiology uh with
with the recombinant nmd receptors
expressed in the centerpiece oocyte
so uh first we we
we mutated all the surrounding residues
in the group and one subunit so as you
can see the only mutations or or residue
substitutions of this asparagine six one
sixth position to uh to alanine or to q
to glutamine can uh got a significant
reduction on the ketamine sensitivity
while others uh residue mutations has
had has had the minimum effect
so with the uh other function data
together we uh we we again we reviewed
that this screw and one aspagin 616 was
confirmed as a key residue to form the
hydrogen bond with ketamine molecule
so next we mutated all the surrounding
residues in the glue and to a subunit so
we observed that only
mutations in the at this losing 642
position can got a significant reduction
on the cation inhibition
in gluon12a receptors
then we systematically mutated
a series of uh substitutions at this
residue
at this position so as you can see that
by mutating this losing to valine or
isoleucine we got a three to five folder
reduction on the ketamine sensitivity
while you shorten the losing side chain
to alanine
we reduce the catamine sensitivity by 50
fold or when we completely remove the
side chain to glycine then you got a 100
time fold reduction on the ketamine
sensitivity
so next we plot this
the ketamine ic50 with the amino acid
the volumes
at this this positions and we got a very
linear fit which implies that this uh
this hydrophobic interactions are highly
steric sensitive
so with all those data together we
confirmed that those hydrophobic
interactions are definitely is the key
binding uh
interaction with this molecule
so uh we were thinking uh try to find a
human mutations and then we looked uh in
the in the human genome
database and we noticed that there's a
three-year-old girl carrying exactly
this mutation at this uh losing 642
position so it's a losing to arginine
with a positively charged residue
mutation so uh it has not been reported
what's the uh problem with this three
year girl i hope she will not have any
depression uh phenotype
in in her life uh but
uh we we just carried out the functional
experiment with this arginine mutation
so as expected you you can see that this
positively charged arginine completely
get rid of the ketamine bonding
so we were thinking uh
we were thinking to make a
knock knocking mice hopefully we can uh
get rid of the ketamine sensitivity in
the knockout mice and the studies the
binding effect
with more in vivo approaches
so uh
then we also
looked at in the gluten 1 2b receptor
structure and we confirmed that this
hydrogen bond and the hydrophobic
interaction are conserved in the glue
and one two b and md receptors so by mu
taking those residues to alanine we also
get a 50 get a 15 fold reduction on the
ketamine sensitivity uh on glue and one
two b receptors so i think in general we
we confirm that those interactions are
conserved in the gluten one n1 2a and
grand 1 2b nmda receptors
so next we needed to explain why
ketamine's
sensitivity was nmd receptor specific
so we did a sequence alignment uh
between the
nmd and the non-nmda uh
ionotropic glutamate receptors uh so as
you can see that
since the asparagine 616 position in in
the group and one subunit so the
homologous site in empire is the uh
group in empire and the kinetics it's
the glutamine or arginine residues so uh
we speculate that this longer side chain
of glutamine and arginine are likely to
cause the steric disruption with cadmium
molecule in empire and kinetic receptors
so also
uh
recent study showed that ketamine's
metabolic hmk display
anti-antidepressant actions through nmda
receptor independent pathways so i think
our structure explained that
this hydroxyl group in hnk can largely
reduce its funding on nmd receptors
through disruption of the hydrophobic
interactions
finally uh in this story so as you you
you might know the catme is typically a
rhythmic mixture with uh s s cadmium and
academic enantiomers
so it has been reported that s cadmium
is three to five times more potent than
academy uh on the nmda receptors but
there are several papers uh mainly with
the with the mice or red models showed
that academy might have long lasting
antidepressant effects and fewer side
effects
so those are done in animal models not
in human beings so we also with our
structure we also did this md
stimulation with our ketamine bond uh
transmembrane domain so uh our md
similar data showed that our academy is
a relatively stable
in its binding pocket but in general i
think the
uh hydrogen and hydrophobic uh
interactions are conserved between s and
r uh categories
so we also carried out a functional
experiment with all
above mentioning the residues by
disrupting the hydrogen and the
hydrophobic interactions so as you can
see that those interactions
are mainly conserved between those two
enantiomers
so uh
additionally we also
noticed that our residue is another
asparagine
61614 residue in the actually on the
glue and 2a subunit
so by mutating this asparagine to
alanine or to glutamine
which we
get a significant reduction on the
academy but not the academy so i think
with all those data together we
explained the the similarity and there's
a difference between those two
enantiomers
so uh with that i would like to show
this movie here so i think in this work
we uh uh
by uh combining the chromium and the
pharmacology we we reviewed the catering
binding site in the human nmda receptors
and by using the functional experiment
and in silico calculation we reviewed
that the hydrogen bond and hydrophobic
interactions as a key
binding
interactions with the academy between
the academy and nmda receptors
so uh i would quickly move to the second
part of my talk
is also a
a recent publication from our group in
neuron so uh in this in this work we try
to
review the molecular basis of the gating
mechanism of the glue and one two a nmda
receptors so we would like to understand
the household this subtype is activated
by the agnes glycine and glutamate
or the how it was
inhibited by the competitive antagonist
cpp or another competitive antagonist
cgp
or how this channel activity was
allosterically modulated by the
modulator or channel blockers
so combining all those uh
pharmacological tools and the cravium
together we eventually uh obtained a
gallery of the glue and one two and md
receptor craving structures actually the
density was pretty decent as you can see
we we got a
very clear density electron density for
most of them those
molecules
we can see that this competitive
uh antagonist cpp so it competes with
the same binding site of the glutamate
while this cgp compound it competes
with the same binding site of the
glycine and this
this gne 6901 so this is a compound
developed by gene tech so as you can see
it's an allosteric potentiator so you
can see that this molecule bond
in between the diamond interface between
the glue and one and the grain to a
ligand binding domain so with all those
structure together we we got uh uh
or by comparing those structures we we
now got a more
uh molecular insight of how the
receptors are activated how the
receptors are inhibited or the receptor
and hysterically modulated so i'm not
going to end uh into the the detail of
this long story i just want to focus on
the my talk with this
non-a bound structure so this is nani is
short for the non amino acid so as you
can see that so we got a very uh nice
density for this molecule so you see the
electron map looks like a diamond with
this amine group facing up to the
electron uh to facing up to the
extracellular domain of the receptor so
we were very confident to fit the this
molecule into this electron density map
so uh this so as you can see the binding
site of this 9a molecule is in this
linker cavity so the linker cavity was
previously sought to only play a role
for the signal transduction uh so it
sends
egg is confirmation extends the uh
confirmation change of the extra
cellular domain and then uh convert this
uh conformation changes to the gate
so people have never discovered
the ligand binding sites in this linker
cavity and the nane was also previously
sought to bind in the same site as the
academy
so we did us based on our structure we
did assist we did the systematically
mutations in the poor region in the
central vestibular region as well as
this linker region so as you can see
that those uh two residues asparagine
616 in the glue and one and the leucine
642 in gram 2a so those two are ketamine
binding residues as i mentioned before
so you can see that those
residues have have
almost no effect on the 9a sensitivity
and eventually we got we we got actually
three mutations in this linker cavity so
actually the three glutamate residues
when we mutate them uh we we got a
significant reduction on the 9a
sensitivity so with all those functional
and also structural uh evidence we
showed that
nanette indeed the binding to this
linker cavity and can also uh modulate
the channel function so uh
in the field that people have never
tested if nane also have some
antidepressant effect in vivo so we are
currently doing that
so i just want to quickly summarize this
part so we discovered a novel uh ligand
binding site in this linker cavity and
we are working on the mechanisms in vivo
so uh
i think i would like to stop my talk
here uh i i think thanks to the crowd em
and we now we are able to decode
the uh structure of all nmda receptor
subtypes
at
atomic resolution i think on one hand
for the basic research
uh uh definitely the tomorrow uh
electron tomography would be the future
it will help us to visualize the
receptor architecture and assemble in
the native synapses or neurons with more
precise spatial and temporal
resolutions
on another hand i think we can
for the drug development with others
high resolution structures
we can do uh ai based uh the novel drug
design and obtain more
uh more compound with the subtype
specificity then we can combine with the
high throughput screening and functional
assays
to obtain more drug candidates for
potential treatment of the neurological
and
psychiatric brain disorders
okay so i'd like to stop with my talk
here
i would like to thank my talented
student to zhang yo-yi and
as well as my collaborator dr rochang
and the doctor efa at shanghai institute
of material medical for this uh for the
kathmandu story i also would like to
thank my student uh wong han hand
and my collaborator pierre parletti uh
for the 9a project
i'd like to thank you everyone in my lab
and thank my fundings and other my other
collaborators
thank you very much for your attention
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you
thank you dr jew for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question
how is cryo em different than other
structural biology techniques does it
open scientific doors but other
structural biology biology techniques
didn't and if so how
uh yeah thank you for the question so i
think in general in structural biology
field there are three main techniques so
one is criem and the other two are x-ray
crystallographer and nmr so before
crying is becoming so popular so i think
the x-ray crystallographer is the main
technique we used in the structural
biology field
so i think the main i think there are
three main advantages of cloud em uh
compared with x-ray crystallographer so
first so it uh it does not need a
crystals so this is the main advantage
because before it
it typically takes for for ion channels
for for membrane proteins it typically
takes three to five years to get to the
crystals
so second i think it requires much less
proteins compared with the x-ray uh
third i think it will i think uh
it uh
it allows the conformational uh
different conformational state
in your protein sample which means that
you can really uh get uh have a uh
how much
a heterogeneous sample but you will
eventually also resolve the structure in
different states yeah so that's the
three um
advantage of of crowley
in my point of view yeah
thank you dr jew the next question here
um do
do cinemalgos monkeys have the same nmda
da receptors
uh
to my analogy i think yes
so uh but i have to check uh we did the
sequence alignment between the human
nmda receptors and the rodent nmda
receptors i think
they are like a
98 percent
conservative yeah
all right thank you our next question
how long does it take for the cryo em
analysis
image acquisition to 3d model
uh
i think it really depends on the protein
so in our case uh
it's usually take like one one month
but
if you really have if you if you have a
very homogeneous sample typically you
will get it like within two weeks yeah
but if your sample is too
heterogeneous maybe you need to try many
times before you get the final structure
all right thank you again dr jew the
next question is
let's see here my screen is jumping i'm
sorry how long does it take to learn how
to do cryo em if you've never done it
before
uh i think several months
okay that doesn't seem like too long and
the next question where can we access
cryo em if we don't have an in-house
cryon electron microscope
uh i think now
i think well i just know the situation
in china so we have like a national
national uh protein center which
is open to all the individual labs and
also a lot of universities and
institutes even even the companies they
they they have
bought crowd em equipment in the past
three years so i think as well they are
very accessible yeah
okay thank you again the next question
what kinds of discoveries do you foresee
being possible with accessible cryo em
uh i think the it will really uh speed
up the the the the basic understanding
of those um
microprotein or protein complex and also
accelerated the the drug discovery
process yeah
okay thank you again
let's see um we have a few more
questions
yes
is there much speed
is there much species diversity in glue
ours i imagine that's like glutamate
receptor but i'm not sure as almost all
in vivo studies are carried out in
rodents
uh
to be honest i think uh
how the eye glue ads are assembled in in
native or in in real brain is is not
completely answered by the field
so there are two
uh
very promising uh studies carried out by
by eric gross the lab from volume
institute so they elucidated so that so
actually actually they extracted the
native empire receptors from the red
brain and then
they do a 3d classification tries to
to visualize the how those receptors and
even the auxiliary proteins are
associated in the real brain so i think
this that will be the future so people
uh
most of the labs who study the ion
channels are using the recombinant
expression system
nowadays but i think for the future
people will jump jump into the native uh
tissue uh try to answer those questions
in in native uh
in native brain yeah
all right thank you dr ju
next question
uh let's see this person says thanks dr
jew wonderful talk could you please
illustrate a bit more what is your plan
to combine cryotomo and ai based drug
design for a new drug
that's a great question so i think that
there are two parts for the crowd thomas
i think we mainly use it for the for the
basic research discovery so as i as i uh
the previous question as i just
mentioned so on one hand we will use the
native extracted
proteins to do a single single particle
uh analysis so uh then the next step
will move to the tomorrow uh term uh
thomas then to visualize how those
receptors
the architecture or the association of
those receptors in the real synapse and
and and the neurons but i think for ai
based drug designers so this is another
part for the application so i think this
we actually we are already doing that so
uh just based on our
structures from single particle
analysis then we we are doing
collaboration with ai people and then to
see we can find more uh nmda specific
drugs yeah based on the structure yeah
all right thank you again our next
question
amazing talk thank you for putting this
together just one question you mentioned
that newer drugs will be designed de
novo do you imagine that newer drugs
will look like ketamine
that's another good question so i think
all those people are doing ketamine and
it's derivatives in the field but all
previous uh derivatives are just
designed based on the ketamine molecule
so we are doing we are doing that based
on the catheter and nmda receptors the
3d conformation the real space uh
structure so we i think that's the major
difference so we will see if was the
dragon which is designed
by ai will also maintain its faster
antidepressant effect
uh we will see i think hopefully i will
tell you the the answer in the in the
next few years yeah
all right thank you again dr ju next
question
uh can you discuss the possible role of
water molecules in the binding of
ketamine to the nmda receptor
uh to be honest at our resolution
between three point five and uh to four
and uh to four angstrom resolution we we
were really not able to see the water
molecule
but it's true even even
we are thinking to do it by by the
modeling by md stimulation yeah but uh
currently the short answer is i don't
know yet but we definitely need would
like to push the resolution and
hopefully we will see see it in the near
future yeah
all right thanks again next question
what is the difficulty in finding the
ketamine binding pocket and what is the
ideal final resolution we need
um
the difficulty is the ketamine ketamine
binding pocket is in the in the
transmembrane domain and the the nmd
receptor is a membrane protein so we
have to extract it from the membrane by
detergent
so so the whole transmembrane domain is
the surrounded by
those dirty detergent so that's the the
the main difficulty yeah
uh ideally uh i think if we can go
beyond uh
beyond three angstrom i think definitely
we can can have a better better
structural insight yeah
all right thank you again our next
question
i would like to ask you why didn't you
choose the other two nmda receptors
glue into c and glue into d
um but instead you chose glue into a and
glue into b for the research
yes this i have mentioned in the
introduction so i think in the in the
adult uh full brain region where where
where like i mentioned the two brain
regions like cortex and the hippocampus
so i think it's grand one two a and two
b they are the main subtypes in both the
brain region yes but we also i think uh
it's a good good
uh question i think if you look at the
sequence alignment in the transmembrane
domain actually the the residue uh for
ketamine binding residues between 2c and
the 2d they are also conserved so i
think the general mechanism for for
ketamine binding is that like they are
probably conserved between
2a to b to c and 2d yeah
all right thank you again our next
question given the importance of the
single single amino acid residues for
ketamine binding to nmda receptors are
there additional or other targets where
ketamine binds in the brain
uh that's a great question actually
people because
people i think in the field that there's
a debate that if ketamine's
antidepressant effect is nmda receptor
dependent or not
uh as you know ketamine is a small
molecule so
uh it's also a dirty drug so if you i
think if you go to really high
concentration catamine can definitely
bind to other receptors and proteins
but i think in the concentration for the
antidepressant as you might know so
typically in clinical trials they use
0.2 to
0.5 milligrams per kilogram so i think
this is very low concentration in my
opinion only nmd receptors are sensitive
to this concentration of ketone molecule
yeah
all right thanks again dr ju next
question and looks like this is the last
one that we have time for
are there any allosteric sites on ndma
receptors that might be helpful
uh yes
so we have another story we are we are
we are we are under review so we find a
group and to
see 2d spec subtype specific
uh allosteric inhibitor which can which
can access to the only to the 2c 2d not
a 2a to b receptors and we also showed
it to have some antidepressant effects
in vivo yeah i think the answer is yes
yeah
oh that's great thank you so much
um do you have any final comments uh for
our audience dr jew before we go
and now thank you for everyone for their
great question yeah
all right well thank you again dr zhu
for your time today and for your
important research we would also like to
thank labruz and our sponsor thermo
fisher scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
bye